The leader of North Korea
just pledged its undying
support for Russia
and what
he calls the “sacred war”
that Russia is fighting
against the West.
Yes, he literally called
it “sacred.”
So Russia and North
Korea are becoming besties,
which is just another example
of the recalibration
that is happening
in the global order.
There's this
growing rebellion
against the U.S.
led Western order.
And Russia
is kind of leading
the charge
here, teaming up
with another outcast,
North Korea,
to condemn the West and say
it's time
to build a different order
away from the United States.
As they do this,
they continue
to frame this all
as very existential,
like Putin called his fight
against Ukraine
“sacred” recently.
And here's Kim
echoing the same sentiment.
This polarizing language,
makes it clear that
this tension between
the West and its enemies
is heating up.
If you want to
better understand global
politics, follow for more.